the character traits that must be
associated that you learn as you go
right because these character traits are
things that have to happen
in order for these skills to be
consistently executed
[Music]
and so it's first you develop the skills
right at a proficient level
then you dive deep on those skills so
that you get better and better at them
and typically
that comes through consistent execution
and repetition which means
that it takes the character traits of
focus and determination
and drive right and being able to be
consistent
and not go like go away and start
looking at shiny objects looking at
chinese objects looking at a new
opportunity looking at
this other side hustle you want to do
whatever it is right because there's
always new things and what's crazy about
this is that the higher up you go
the more seductive the woman in the red
dress looks like
and i'm saying that from matrix is my
all-time favorite movie um
the woman in the red dress i'm using
this as a
as a parable or whatever a visual for
opportunity
and when you're starting out the woman
in the red dress always
looks attractive and the thing is is
that the higher up you go
the more pretend she becomes now if
you're a girl then
i don't know a guy in a red suit
whatever i don't know maybe that looks
more like a pimp said forget about that
but whatever
you know george clooney or whoever your
person is whatever you my point
is um like i thought that i was having
discipline and saying no to
a certain level opportunity when i was
starting my gyms right and i had to
develop that discipline
and then we started and then we started
making a few million dollars a year and
i was like okay
i need to develop a new level discipline
because there's more things that
i want to do that i have to not be able
to do right one of the biggest
successful things i did was not start
the supplement company until a year and
a
half
after almost two years after gym one
started all right
i had planned starting the supplement
company
at the same time as i started gym launch
original
three and a half four years ago like
they were at the same time i wanted to
do both
and layla the angel that she is was like
no
that's stupid don't do that and so
she thankfully was like you have to have
you have to stay focused and so because
of that we were able to have the
explosive growth that we did and then at
the right time we were able to bolt that
on
now um big big big big picture
i don't know if i would have done it
again i still probably would have stayed
even more focused
on gym launch if i could do it all over
again now
we have it you know we we write a check
for 600 000
every single month to our gym lords uh
in terms of commission check so that's
real money that i get to send back to
the community and that's very fulfilling
fulfilling for me
um and it solved the problem that i
always had when i have my gym so like
there are reasons that i did it um and
uh and so
like history will tell whether it was
the right call or not um i can never
live the life of what it would have been
if i hadn't done it um
but i think if i were going back in time
knowing what i've known now i might not
have done it
um but you never know so i'm telling you
like i've i've made these mistakes you
know what i mean
and the thing is is that that level of
opportunity looked
even more seducting or seducing or
whatever the word is
um when we had two years more of a
distribution base compared to when we
had at the beginning
and so i wasn't able to say no to her
that opportunity later on as i was in
the
beginning
and that was a deficiency in my skill
set
at the time my character trait of
staying focused
right and so um like i'm saying all this
if you're looking at it in terms of
in verticals the first step is filling
the holes and that's stacking all the
skills together so you can get the first
dollar to go over
and that's just becoming proficient not
amazing just proficient you don't have
to be an expert at running traffic you
just need to be able to actually know
how to run an ad
and the thing is is that most proficient
skills only take
like like not a lot of time like you can
google how to do x
and if you consume for like two hours of
information you'll probably be
proficient most people just don't take
those two hours to do it because it's
uncomfortable and you're not good at it
right so you consume the information and
then you try
right and then you fail because you're
not good at it you learn and then just
use those first initial tries you learn
more in your first 20 sales
than you do in the first 20 hours of
learning about sales stuff
right you first time you actually step
in the ring you learn more about
fighting than you do during all the time
that you're practicing right
because it's real right so you're
developing you're stacking your skills
and you're becoming proficient at it
next step you have to do re repetition
and be
being willing to get punched in the face
over and over and over again right so
that you can
deepen those skills and that's what
amplifies the skills that you have so
that you can get to
another level then as you get to another
level
then your character traits need to be
strong so you can stay the course
all right like the biggest thing in the
book uh by angela duckworth called grit
which is really interesting
um is that the people who are most
successful in life just stick with it
like greatness stick-to-it-ness is what
it is
so it's how likely are you to abandon a
certain path
to pursue another thing right and the
people in the beginning have very low
stick with it-ness entrepreneurs
shiny objects shiny object shiny object
they're jumping from opportunity to
opportunity and they never give any of
the opportunities a chance
to be successful so one of the
interesting things that maybe you can
think about in terms of a quote
that you can take with you is you can be
successful
anything you want just not everything
you want
all right that was a huge lesson for me
all right i had a i had a friend from
high school who reached out
who had a contracting business and a
roofing business and they were flipping
houses so it's three separate businesses
and i was like dude like like what do
you want help with he was like i don't
know like
what do you think i should do and i was
like pick one he's like well we're
making money in all three of them and i
was like cool
pick one each one of those businesses
can be a billion dollar business
you can be a billion dollar roofing
company you can be a billion dollar
flipping homes company
you can be a billion dollar general
contractor there are examples of each of
these things
right but you just can't be a billion
dollars in all of them
and so there's a fallacy that we tell
ourselves as entrepreneurs which is that
if i do more things i will make more
money when in fact i need to do fewer
things
to get to where i want to go and the
reason i can tell you that it's the
truth is because you naturally think the
other way
and that's what most people think which
is why most people aren't successful
right it's they can't focus because
there's too many things it's just so
easy just add this one thing you do this
other thing and all of a sudden you're
two spread thin
you're not focused on amplifying the
things that you're doing to get better
you're not
deepening the skills you're spreading
yourself there right and so once you
acquire the skill set once you become
proficient
then you amplify the skills that you
have by deepening them and in order to
deepen them
you have to have the character traits of
sticking with it being patient
being focused learning to say no and
doing things over and over again
and accepting the fact that it may take
years it will take years
in order to become to break through the
next level of proficiency because
when you're developing a skill um let me
give you an example with
to tie this as an analogy for fitness
the amount of effort that it takes to
maintain muscle
versus the amount of effort it takes to
make muscle as you become more advanced
dramatically increases and what's
interesting is that there's this big
area of no man's land between enough to
maintain and
enough to break through and create a new
stimulus for growth
there's this huge area in the middle and
most people just work out
above minimum effective dose but below
the threshold that it takes to adapt
all right and so when we focus or when i
focus on trying to get swole and trying
to gain more muscle
i try and go all the way to the other
end to break my body the point that it
has to adapt and get better
right and so with the same thing with
skill sets is that
there's a minimum effective dose and
then there's a whole bunch of area in
between where people do stuff enough but
not enough to get better
but still like they could take the extra
time allocate it towards deepening a
skill and going all in on it
um it and really push that forward and
really deepen it
rather than just consistently
maintaining where you're at and you can
know if you're maintaining where you're
at because if your level of income has
stayed the same
for a period of years that means your
skill set has stayed the same
and if your skill set has stayed the
same it's usually because you lack the
character traits
in order to deepen those skills to
amplify the revenue and to amplify your
skill sets so that you can make more
all right so um i hope this makes sense
uh this was like one of the
one of the many things that i'll
probably talk about after um the summit
um so leveling up why we get stuck and
it's because the things that you need to
improve on
are different all right in the beginning
it's skills but then you have to change
your lens
and then after that it becomes traits
right it becomes character traits
and those are very different to level up
right because everyone just always
assumes it's going to be linear the same
way
and that's why people get stuck is
because the actual thing that you need
to improve changes
right not just skills but the actual
nature of the change itself
changes uh which is pretty cool and um
sometimes the skill itself is to not do
other things
right sometimes the skill itself is
maintaining the course
and that is the skill that is the thing
that you need to do to get to the next
level
is to do less and it's remove
constraints so i hope that makes sense
for you i hope you enjoyed that if you
did like this and you're
listening on the podcast drop a comment
drop a like um if you think someone else
will listen to it
tag them tag your friends hope you have
an amazing day and lots of love as
always
keep being great
[Music]
you